HBO is developing a new Game of Thrones prequel
show based on George R.R. Martin’s Tales
of Dunk and Egg, which follow the adventures
of Ser Duncan the Tall (Dunk) and young Aegon
V Targaryen (Egg) 90 years prior to the events
of “A Song of Ice and Fire.” To some of
you, this might come as a huge, unexpected
surprise, but I've been waiting for this confirmation
for quite some time. On February 10th, 2013,
George R.R. Martin confirmed that he’d been
in discussion with HBO over a possible adaptation
of the Tales of Dunk and Egg short stories
and ever since I knew it would sooner or later
be official.
The Game of Thrones ended in 2019. The Game
of Thrones prequel series, House of the Dragon,
will air in 2022. And now, Variety reports
that HBO is in early stages of developing
another, as-yet unnamed spinoff show based
on George R.R. Martin’s Tales of Dunk and
Egg. The Tales of Dunk and Egg is an ongoing
series of prequel novellas written by George
R. R. Martin, set in the world of A Song of
Ice and Fire. The stories relate the adventures
of the hedge knight Ser Duncan the Tall, who
would become a legendary member of the Kingsguard,
and his squire Egg, who would become King
Aegon V Targaryen of Westeros. Although Egg
is a boy at the start of the series, he will
eventually grow up to become King Aegon V,
or "Aegon the Unlikely". The stories begin
with their meeting 90 years before the events
of Game of Thrones, and may cover the events
until the deaths of Duncan and King Aegon.
Martin has published three novellas in the
“Tales of Dunk and Egg” series to date:
“The Hedge Knight” in 1998, “The Sworn
Sword” in 2003, and “The Mystery Knight”
in 2010.
The three novellas were then collected and
published together as “A Knight of the Seven
Kingdoms” in 2015. The Tales of Dunk and
Egg begin 90 years before the War of the Five
Kings,
at the end of the reign of King Daeron II
Targaryen. The realm is still recovering from
the First Blackfyre Rebellion thirteen years
before, a great civil war that tore the Seven
Kingdoms in half. Daeron II's bastard half-brother
Daemon Blackfyre had tried to seize the throne
in the rebellion, but was killed in the final
battle of the war. Several of his sons survived
by fleeing into exile, and across the Narrow
Sea, House Blackfyre is continually plotting
all manner of intrigues against the main branch
of the Targaryen dynasty, hoping to gain support
for new rebellions. The Targaryens are still
having difficulty maintaining their hold on
power, particularly since the last of their
dragons died fifty years ago, and the beasts
are starting to fade from living memory. There
are also lingering tensions from the recent
unification of Dorne with the rest of the
Seven Kingdoms. The fiercely independent Dornishmen
had resisted Targaryen conquest for two centuries,
and only finally came under the authority
of the Iron Throne through peaceful marriage-alliance.
Daeron II married the sister of the Prince
of Dorne, and Daeron II's sister married the
Prince of Dorne. The terms of the alliance
led to the Iron Throne giving House Martell
of Dorne preferential treatment, with a strong
pro-Martell faction developing around Daeron
II at the royal court. This is one of the
factors that sparked the Blackfyre Rebellion,
as all of the non-Dornish lords who felt that
the pro-Martell faction was receiving royal
favors which should have been theirs ultimately
sided with Daemon Blackfyre. Despite thirteen
years of relative peace, relations between
the Dornish and the rest of the Seven Kingdoms
remain tenuous. Worse problems are on the
horizon, as during the course of Dunk and
Egg's first adventures a massive plague known
as the Great Spring Sickness sweeps across
the Seven Kingdoms (Westeros' equivalent of
the Black Death), upsetting what was already
a fragile political balance. With plague and
drought devastating the Seven Kingdoms, many
turn to banditry to survive, and the roads
are crawling with outlaw bands. Petty feuds
erupt between local lords competing over food
and resources. With the realm weakened from
within, dangers arise on every side,
as the Targaryens' enemies see their vulnerable
state as a perfect opportunity to attack.
Besides the continuing tensions with the Dornish
to the south, the Blackfyres across the eastern
sea are attempting to raise new armies in
the Free Cities, and to turn lords in Westeros
to their side who are upset at the difficulties
the Targaryen reign is encountering. To the
west, the ironborn led by Dagon Greyjoy are
seizing their best chance in generations to
return to the Old Way, conducting brazen coastal
raids from Bear Island in the North to The
Arbor in the south. To the north the wildlings
have been united by a new King-Beyond-the-Wall,
Raymun Redbeard, and they are preparing to
cross over the Wall and sweep through the
lands to the south. Into this backdrop steps
Ser Duncan the Tall, a very large squire who
grew up as an orphan in the slums of Flea
Bottom in King's Landing. A hedge knight,
Ser Arlan of Pennytree, has died during the
night. His squire, a large young man named
Dunk, buries him and pays his last respects.
After considering several options, Dunk decides
to continue his journey to Ashford and compete
in the tourney as a knight. He adopts Ser
Arlan's armor as his own, as well as his equipment,
three horses, and remaining monies. At an
inn on the road, he meets a boy with a shaved
head named Egg who secretly follows him to
Ashford. Impressed by the boy's spirit, Dunk
takes him on as his own squire for the upcoming
tourney. At Ashford, Dunk sells one of his
horses to commission armor, then attempts
to enter the lists of the tourney. Without
proof of his knighthood, he’s nearly barred
from competition until Prince Baelor Targaryen
vouches for him. Dunk watches the first day
of competition amongst the commoners, with
Egg on his shoulders. After several spectacular
tilts, the day ends when Prince Aerion Targaryen
disgraces himself by killing Ser Humfrey Hardyng's
horse. That night, Egg informs Dunk that a
puppeteer girl he had met earlier is being
beaten by Prince Aerion. Dunk leaps to her
defense and attacks Aerion, striking him in
the face. As a royal guard arrests Dunk, Egg
reveals himself to be Aerion's brother, Prince
Aegon Targaryen, commonly known by his nickname
"Egg", a grandson of King Daeron II. In jail,
Dunk chooses to take a trial by combat rather
than losing his hand.
Prince Aerion demands the combat to be a Trial
of Seven, as his brother, Prince Daeron, also
accused Dunk of kidnapping Aegon from his
charge. Dunk must find six champions to fight
with him against seven accusing knights, or
he will forfeit. Steffon Fossoway is the first
ally - Dunk finds - and he and Egg bring more
champions to Dunk’s cause. The fourteen
champions line their mounts - along opposite
sides of the tourney grounds and charge. Dunk
tilts against Aerion, but is quickly unhorsed.
Altough nearly defeated, Dunk manages to grapple
Aerion and use his size advantage to pummel
Aerion into submission. Aerion recants his
accusation, ending the Trial. The fighting
costs the lives of both Humphreys. Prince
Baelor, who had not brought his own armor,
but instead wore armor made for his son, took
a blow to the head from a mace. After the
battle, Baelor approaches Dunk to congratulate
him, and begins to act drunkenly. When his
crushed helm is removed, it’s shown that
the weaker armor made for his son did not
protect him from the blow which has crushed
in his skull. Aerion's father, Maekar, meets
with Dunk after the funeral, revealing that
it was his mace that killed Baelor.
He regrets Aerion's behavior and offers Dunk
a position in his household to train Aegon.
Dunk insists on being allowed to travel, and
offers to take Aegon as his squire to learn
to be a better knight than Aerion. Maekar
agrees, making sure Aegon continues to use
his alias of Egg to avoid scandal. Dunk and
Egg set out to Dorne, in search of the puppeteer
whom Dunk had saved. Through a series of many
adventures the unlikely duo of "Dunk and Egg"
will, in the course of years, rise to great
fame, as Egg grows to become King Aegon V,
and Dunk becomes Ser Duncan the Tall, Lord
Commander of the Kingsguard. Martin has said
that the novellas will include time-jumps
so that they will ultimately cover the rest
of the lives of the two main characters, stretching
across a period of 50 years, until both of
them die in the Tragedy of Summerhall. This
will bridge the timeline between the two main
narrative eras: Ser Barristan Selmy was knighted
at the age of sixteen by King Aegon V after
unhorsing Ser Duncan in a joust. Tywin Lannister's
grandfather Gerold Lannister is a character
in the early novellas, but young Tywin was
a boy when Aegon V died. Prince Rhaegar Targaryen
was also born the very same night as the Tragedy
at Summerhall. No writer or talent is currently
attached to the project, but sources say it’s
a high priority for HBO as the premium cabler
looks to build on the success of “Game of
Thrones.” Should the project go to series,
it would be the second “Game of Thrones”
prequel to make it to screen. The network
is currently prepping the series “House
of the Dragon,” which is slated to debut
in 2022. That show will document the buildup
to the Targaryen civil war in Westeros that’s
known as the Dance of Dragons.
Fans have been calling for a “Tales of Dunk
and Egg” TV series for some time now and
now we might finally get it. It’s important
to note that HBO has just started developing
this show,
but it's good to know that we'll get more
of Westeros and its stories. In the meantime,
we have another Game of Thrones prequel, House
of the Dragon, to keep us in touch with the
magic world of Westeros, which will be about
Targaryen history and which is going to air
in 2022. Thank you guys so much for watching,
and let me know which Game of Thrones prequel
excites you more; Tales of Dunk and Egg or
House of the Dragon. If you enjoyed this video
please give it a big thumbs up and I hope
to see you in the next one. Peace!